morning everybody
um welcome everyone to today's meeting
of the licensing board so um fire alarm
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated please take the stairs down to
the reception area and out of the
building to the Green in Hawley Square
which is the assembly point please do
not use the lifts officers will assist
you and advise when it's deemed safe to
return to council offices filming at the
meeting
um does anyone wish to film the meeting
no okay restriction on the use of mobile
phones would everyone present please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned to silent and they are not used
to make or receive phone calls whilst
the meeting is in progress
and apologies for absence um do we have
any apologies for absence
no I have apologies from counselor wing
and counselor
Dennis
[Laughter]
expressions of Interest
are there any Declarations of Interest
no
um minutes of the last licensing board
meeting 22nd of November 22. please can
I have a member proposed and second at
the minutes of the licensing board
meeting held on 22nd of November be
approved councilor at Saunders and
councilor Huxley
um
okay an agenda item number four minutes
of the last licensing board meeting
um 14th of February
um 2023 please can I remember proposed
in second at the minutes of the
licensing board meeting held on the 14th
of February 2023 be approved as a
correct record
um so
um councilor Rogers is proposing and
Council Dexter seconding minutes of the
last sorry agenda item five minutes of
the last licensing board meeting 21st of
March 2023
um please can I have a member proposed
and second at the minutes of the
licensing board meeting held on the 21st
of March 23 be approved as a correct
record
um councilor shrub is proposing
um and Council Dexter second in
minutes of the last licensing
subcommittee please can I have a member
proposed in a second that the minutes of
the licensing subcommittee meeting held
on the 22nd of March 23 be approved as a
correct record
um
Curry second in
exclusion of public and press police
government proposed and second that the
public and press can be excluded from
the meeting for agenda items eight and
nine as it contains exempt information
as defined in paragraph 7 or of part one
of schedule 12a of the Local Government
Act 72 as amended
can I have a prize against the shrub
counselor Rogers
thank you